hello and welcome to my latest uh
leaders briefing it's December now so
I'm we're all on the countdown to
Christmas and I hope you're looking
forward to uh to spending a bit of time
with your family and enjoying some
delicious turkey and opening a few
presents I know we all are here at
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
um Christmas we know is also a really
hard time for some of our families and
even more so at the moment as we're
going through the cost of living crisis
hopefully you've seen from our last
leaders briefing and from our Northeast
harborshire news and our website that
we're doing a lot of work at the moment
to try and support our residents and our
businesses and and communities and and
all of our all of our population around
um dealing with the impacts of the cost
of living crisis whether that's in terms
of energy saving advice helping you to
sort of manage your bills or signposting
people to other forms of community
support or really explaining some of the
government support that's out there and
trying to help people to access that um
and another thing that we've recently
done as a council is commit to employing
two new community outreach workers whose
job it will be to go out into the
community and to support residents
particularly those who are particularly
struggling at the moment into accessing
some of that additional support and to
help them in terms of managing finances
so we're really pleased about that it's
a really important part of being able to
support Northeast Derbyshire through the
cost of living crisis and our key
message to all of our communities and
all of our residences if you or anyone
you know needs our support or needs any
help whatsoever please don't hesitate to
get in touch don't leave it in too long
just get in touch with us and we'll do
whatever we can to support you and we
stand ready to support everyone who
needs it through this difficult period
that we're going through now the
Northeast aubergine news magazine also
includes lots of other handy tips over
the over the festive period things like
our opening times both the district
council building here at Mill Lane and
our Leisure centers who obviously some
changes to opening times over that
Christmas period but also in terms of
the the bin Collections and we'll all be
aware that green bean collections have
been suspended over the winter period
and we know that obviously Christmas is
a time with lots of wrapping paper and
presents and recycling so there's also
some information there in the in the
news magazine about how to deal your
recycling and also who to contact in the
case of an emergency situation where you
need the district council's help
particularly during those periods where
we're closed down so do check out the
the news magazine there's lots of useful
handy tips there that'll hopefully help
Christmas be as smooth as it possibly
can now we know that Christmas is also a
time when unfortunately some people
choose to take advantage so there's lots
of useful information on our website
about how to protect yourself from
burglaries which can be so disheartening
and so upsetting for families during the
Christmas period there's loads of
information on our website so do check
it out about keeping yourself safe and
keeping all of your Christmas
possessions safe during this during this
winter period
now moving on to a bit of different news
the government have recently launched a
uk-wide veterans survey and we're
encouraging all veterans within the
Northeast Derbyshire area to contribute
to that and go online and and fill it
out it's running for about 12 weeks
starting in November so it's still got a
bit of time to to complete that if you
haven't yet already and it's all about
the government listening to and hearing
from the experiences of veterans around
the services that we provide and and the
support that's out there and available
to them so please do go on the go on the
website the government's website and and
fill in the survey if you are a veteran
in Northeast Derbyshire
and again sticking with the theme of
veterans we recently were awarded the
Armed Forces Gold Award as part of the
Armed Forces Covenant and you might be
aware of this from previous leaders
briefings we're one of only about 630
Employers in the whole country out of
about 7 million employers who've been
awarded this really prestigious award by
the ministry of defense and our Armed
Forces Champion councilor Martin Thacker
recently was presented with the award by
Bruce Spencer who's the regional
coordinator for the scheme working for
the ministry of Defense it's a great
achievement for the council we're really
really proud of it and it's really
Testament to our real commitment to
supporting those in the armed forces for
a reservist and obviously for Veterans
as well so really proud of that and
obviously we hope to continue to
maintain that high level of standard in
terms of service to those people moving
on again we're also offering some free
digital training to over 50s at the
moment so if you or anyone you know
might be interested in that and finding
out more please go on our website it's
as I say it's free and it never hurts to
brush up on your skills particularly in
this very digital world that we're
living in now so please do check it out
I think it's a great opportunity and
hopefully lots of residents over 50s in
particular in Northeast Derbyshire will
make good use of that from some of my
recent leaders briefings you'll be aware
of the the moves I thought at the moment
towards the Devolution deal for the East
Midlands so this is about
Nottinghamshire and Nottingham City and
Derbyshire and Derby City working
together to get a Devolution deal from
the government which could mean
substantial investment in the region and
having an elected mayor to cover that
whole area there's a consultation that's
currently out at the moment it runs for
several weeks into the new year so
please go on the the website the East
Midlands Devolution deal consultation
website to give your views on on what
you think that might mean for the region
now a bit of breaking news now is that
we've just found out from the government
that we've been awarded our 2.58 million
pounds from the UK shared Prosperity
fund now again I've probably referred to
this in previous leaders briefings but
this is a funding from the government
following the our departure from the
European Union and it's all about
investing in communities it's about
we're using our uh our pot for Northeast
Derbyshire if you like to support things
like investing in parks and play areas
improving shop Frontage improving
Village Hall facilities helping people
with skills and trying to support people
getting into work so it's all those
sorts of things we we have a lot of
flexibility around how we want to use
that and in North East Derbyshire we've
tried to focus it on really visible
things that people will see as
improvements in their community and
that's absolutely the right thing to do
and we're really pleased to have that
funding now confirmed by the government
and hopefully you'll see start to see
some of those improvements happening
over the next over the few months and
years it's a three-year deal so it will
take time to deliver but yeah we're
really pleased to be able to get
cracking now and and get starting in
terms of investing into some of our
really important Community projects
another really key project for us is the
rebuild of Charlie Park Leisure Center
now you'll know from previous leaders
briefings again that this has been a big
project for us we've already approved
the budget for it it's it's a 23 million
pound project involving quite a
significant Council investment but also
we've got funding from the claycross
town deal and from other partners like
sport England which we're trying to
secure at the moment and so we've got
the project all been lined up it's gone
through the planning process and now
we're very very close now literally
within the next few days to signing the
contract and that means that work will
hopefully start quite early on in the
New Year sort of January February time
we'll start to see a bit more activity
on site and I know for lots of residents
in Clay Cross they've heard about this
scheme for a long long time and I think
the the general perception is that we
keep hearing about it but it's not
happening yet well now now we're in the
stage finally where actually you're
going to start out seeing some of the
works on the ground and I think that's
really important demonstration of our
commitment to deliver this vital project
and look forward to seeing it come to
fruition it's not going to be a quick
process it's still going to take almost
two years to deliver the new Leisure
Center but I'm really excited about
seeing it when it's done because I've
seen from the visuals that it looks
absolutely fantastic and it's going to
make such a difference to all the
residents in Clay Cross and The Wider
Villages that that Charlie Park serves
now one of the issues that I know is a
key concern for a lot of residents in
Northeast Derbyshire is the issue of
fracking now you'll probably hopefully
be aware that there was a moratorium
introduced by the government which
essentially banned fracking it stopped
fracking from happening anywhere in the
country that was introduced in 2019
however following some of the changes in
government recently fracking was put for
a short period of time back on the table
now that Rishi sunax in in post the
moratorium has been put back in place
and that means very clearly that there
will be no fracking applications coming
forward in Northeast Derbyshire but I'm
really pleased that as a council we've
unanimously on a sort of cross-party
basis agreed a recent council meeting
that we would reaffirm our commitment to
opposing any fracking in Northeast
Derbyshire should it ever come back onto
the table and I'm really pleased that we
could vote together as you know speak
with one voice on that issue because I
know how important it is for so many of
our communities in terms of that fear
that it might happen again so we've got
good news in terms of the moratorium
back in place and I just want to
reassure everyone of Northeast
Derbyshire District council's commitment
to oppose it should it ever come back on
the table
one of the other things that I've been
doing recently is spending a bit more
time back to the floor with some of our
staff around different services within
the council so you'll be aware hopefully
that earlier in the year myself and the
deputy leader of the council councilor
Charlotte keep it spent a shift each
with some of our refuse teams both in
the North and the South of the district
you know emptying bins and I really
enjoyed the experience and and learned a
lot about the work that they do day in
day out to keep keep the district moving
really and you know how how lost we
would be without them so as well as
spending some time out on the bins I
also recently went to dronfield sports
center for a morning and spent the
morning with staff learning a bit more
about how the Leisure centers operate I
did a backwash on one of the pools and
did some health and safety checks and
also spent some time with some of the
lifeguards doing a uh doing a mock
Theory exam which I'm afraid to say I
didn't pass unfortunately but no it's
really great to spend that time with the
Leisure service and understand a bit
more about their work and and about how
the Leisure centers operate and I really
did leave feeling like they they run
like a really well-oiled machine I was
really assured in terms of the work that
they do to support each other okay
finally all that's left me to do is to
say please do continue checking our
website and our social media channels
and also the Northeast Derbyshire news
magazine for all the latest news and
information and how to get in touch with
us and all I can say is uh I wish you
all a very merry Christmas and a happy
New Year and a huge thank you to all of
our residents and our businesses and
really importantly all of our staff here
at Northeast Derbyshire District Council
have a well-deserved break and I look
forward to seeing you in the new year
foreign